you're afraid of making a video when
there's a lot of people but this is this
is now where you start building massive
confidence this is it this is it you
walk into the train station you're
terrified terrified I have to make a
video terrified right
I don't have to make your video I'm
terrified right feel you're ready
terrified thinking about it okay so you
feel like I'm terrified awesome
then you have to go find the busiest
part in the train station go there and
then with intention use and find the
busiest point not under the stairwell
somewhere the busiest part and then you
go make your video be brutal be like I
came Canada I was already hair stylist
in Japan certified and I came to Canada
I wanted to be your hair stylist
okay be able to speak English okay and
then I get married I have a kids yeah
and then somehow I mean I get busy yeah
so I was cutting hair on the side yeah
but I still haven't got Ontario license
here okay so when my youngest one wanted
to turn one year old and I just like I
can just hear it my voice you gotta take
a license this is not what you're doing
I was cleaning rooms housekeeping yeah
right I was doing something I don't
really I gotta do to make money okay so
I just like you know you go you have a
license you have a dream you got to do
it so my voice getting louder so I just
like I gotta do it yeah so I wanted to
challenge but there was nobody else you
know you're Falls around me had license
I mean Japanese Japanese nobody yeah so
I couldn't get enough resource okay I
wanna get to doing something there are a
lot of souvenirs store in Niagara Falls
just owned by Japanese people yeah
so I starting to search search search
finally ooh license and then what I'm
gonna do and I gotta just search my own
to find a job and then I gotta search my
own to find the supplies right and then
after that I just starting to have on a
home so long I just didn't know I start
from zero so just not much really
resource anything so that's why if
somebody else want to get to start
something if I have knowledge maybe I
can be a help so what I love about you
is you you have the hustle and drive to
try to make something better you know so
even showing up here you woke up at 3:00
in the morning there 3:30 to 3:30 in the
morning to get here today this morning
show and it wasn't even it's like you're
gonna get up you're gonna do the work
you're gonna you're gonna try you've
come a couple times over here to be a
part too
you're trying to get better where for a
lot of people it's easy to say well I'm
just gonna be I'll just be a hairdresser
and this would be my life yeah well
you're you're actively trying to improve
your network improve your knowledge to
then go out and have a big move back
which I really respect and love a lot of
people come over a lot of people say
well I had all the success over in
another country I come here and you just
accept the life that's less than so you
stay cleaning houses forever I have a
process that's that I think really helps
for people are trying to find the
purpose trying to find the next path
it's just with the who so the who was
your one word so you have your one word
what's your one with my one word is be
yourself okay yes I put Beauty are you
Japanese okay
like maybe that knows kanji very so is
your one word a Japanese character
Japanese symbol it'd be okay and be
yourself okay means like we've put most
of you for the women okay if the woman's
be yourself
I think it's beauty any age
from within okay that's awesome like I
want to see like the one word via
Japanese okay so so it starts with the
hoop right yes then there's the Y so
your purpose comes from your pain it's
like why is this so important so to be
yourself awesome like that's gonna be
the rock that you stand on but then the
purpose so for me believe the Y
entrepreneurs entrepreneurship because I
suffered so much as an entrepreneur as I
struggled because I wasn't making any
money in the early days and I don't want
anybody to have to go through what I
went through so why I love helping
entrepreneurs is I want to help them not
suffer that same fate that I went
through your best moments in being hair
stylist will be when you can help them
be themselves and gain more confidence
yes yeah yeah and so if you make that an
intention into every haircut I want to
help this person be themselves and I
want to help them gain more confidence I
mean you're in the be yourself and
confidence business that's your business
that's your life that's what you do
forever yep when you're 70 years old
you're still gonna want to help people
do themselves and get more confidence if
anything you just want it more as you
start building traction momentum that's
that's what you want to do forever I'm
gonna believe in people forever if you
imagine you're holding an umbrella
that's the stem like that's the handle
that's the whole like the main piece of
the umbrella okay cutting hair is one of
the spokes so I can umbrella you got the
you got the handle and then you got
these folks that come down the side
right and it all supports the umbrella
so haircutting is one of your spokes you
know what I do it all day long
but it's important you know you don't
want to quit you're not gonna stop being
a hairstylist but it only you only want
to do it a certain amount of time every
day but you're not in the hairstyling
business during the confidence building
business and so thinking about how
people find you thinking about what's on
your Instagram thinking about the actual
location yes the physical environment so
you've got one thing on the wall that
says beauty is see the beauty yeah
awesome like maybe it says be yourself
right oh but what you like what else
could you do so that as soon as I walk
into your hair salon yeah it's different
you still need to have the mirrors you
soon they have the chairs you still do
have all the stuff that yeah right but I
want to feel like I can be myself yeah
and I can gain confidence just by
walking in before I even have yeah
before I even meet you before you even
say hi like just walking in if I would
have come your hair song and you weren't
there I would feel more confident and
more willing to be myself just by being
in their space so everything that you
touch everything that you do every
conversation that you have is designed
around helping people be themselves at
home
some people would be like I'm just a
hair stylist it's all I'm gonna do I cut
hair I feel good about it I make money
it's a life that's most people most
people will just do their job make
enough money never really be happy yeah
they don't necessarily hate their life
but it's just okay it's just living
where you're like no I want more yeah
when I say I'm just a hair stands like a
home I'm just a hair studies yeah when I
say that I can feel something like
shrink right yeah this is not exactly
what my heart's want to say yeah but I
don't have enough confidence say I'm a
hair stylist yeah I can inspire all the
girls yes I mean the girls around me
yeah I can create the woman or like
atomosphere and then when people comes
to get haircut my clients come to get a
haircut yeah we would smile yes
confidence I'm that kind of hair stuff
yeah but you don't have the confidence
to say that yet you getting there a 60%
okay but today today maybe it boost up
like 88
yeah but that but how like this this is
what super interesting how this coming
here you know being on a live show
yeah how does that help you have more
confidence to be a hair stylist right
and and of course to make sense but like
that that's that's that's the a lot of
people would say only like stick stick
within hair style I mean it get more
training but the ultimate thing is gonna
be when you lean in the things that
scare you coming and doing this now
going back home when doing hair styling
is not is not as scary anymore no but
what if I want to do this I want to just
started doing this and that
what if fam
because it comes from love they don't
want to they worry so much yeah
the family said that's great idea yeah
whatever the family issue is the more
that you do the thing like I just need
to do it yeah you do so do it do it yeah
yeah permission give yourself permission
but like here's the thing I don't you
shouldn't do it because I said it's okay
to do it I know I know what to write I
could have come and said no listen to
your family right now you should be like
know everything get out of here you suck
you know but you need to do it you need
to do you already know you need to do it
and you don't need my permission and my
answers you need to give yourself
permission to go out and do it and you
already are it's something you're not
but you need to do it in a bigger way
you need to embrace it more fully yeah
you need to be yourself the more you are
doing things you are not yourself and
you don't have confidence in the more
you're gonna lose respect for yourself
and not be happy I don't mean I don't
have I don't like it
of course cuz your things about being
yourself so the more you're not being
yourself the more you're gonna be
unhappy if you are unhappy it's because
you're in a situation where you not
allowed to be yourself you're not doing
anything in your business to be against
people in your family you're not gonna
make a business saying my mom sucks I
know my son he's in Japan okay I you
know hopefully he's watching okay
probably he's just like mom you suck
maybe not but they love me like the way
to inspire the kids is not through the
words or through your actions right like
seeing you come here and being afraid
and yeah I'm doing the thing anyway is
the ultimate inspiration but then maybe
he goes and he asked that girl out
because he saw you be courageous here
right doesn't mean that most people want
to come and do this but seeing anybody
act courageously well I've seen anybody
face a fear and be confident through it
will inspire them to have a little bit
more confidence in their lives I do
I'd like to series girlboss the best all
process I jump into the girl box
although we're looking at doing a 254
girl was 254 girl boss 254 yes oh your
confidence it's right up your alley yes
yeah today I was up too early so I
haven't kept I didn't come in yet right
cuz it comes at 5:00 a.m. yeah yeah but
I watch every day yeah and that built
confidence yeah it's just everyday first
in the morning yeah before I watch
anything else
yep but see that's the thing like that's
what you can do for people to not even
in that format of a video or an email
every day but the exposure to it daily
starts to shift perspective if you're
around if you're around me yeah you're
gonna believe in yourself more it's just
gonna happen if you're gonna be sucked
into my vortex yeah yeah it's going to
happen
yeah there's no option believe I'm on my
rock and Anna you're not gonna push me
for my rock yeah ever right so you will
be sucked in yep and so it it's just
like if you're around people who are
working out all the time you're gonna
want to are gonna start working out more
right if you're around people who are
eating healthy all the time you're gonna
want to eat healthy wherever wherever
that person is weak if you're strong at
you will bring them in so just like the
250 for confident series is helping you
and helping other people who are
learning that same idea of if somebody's
around you regularly every day every
week every month the consistent exposure
to you will make them feel more
comfortable
if you make that your intention that I'm
gonna the more that you are being
yourself yeah even without trying
even without like making videos and
trying to spread a message the more you
are being yourself you'll inspire the
people around you
to be themselves to what's another way
that you can be yourself that is to take
home something you're afraid to do the
day I post and Twitter first time I mean
the videos I'm generally to that a
little bit I felt something yeah outside
I was so some people were there to your
videos like oh the but if people judge
me and they go she's following herself
right selfies and something but I just
like I would do it because I somehow
like just I want to be myself yeah
just explore yeah you're taking a train
back home there are lots of people on
the train
I have to do the tree okay
is it is it are you worried about
judgment in a lot of people yes yeah not
by much like you know you know just so
here's the thing here's the thing you
get the train station early right you're
gonna get the train station before the
train leaves okay so I will yeah so
you're afraid of of doings you're afraid
of making a video when there's a lot of
people feel the judge yes if you're if
you're still still great we're doing it
like nobody's here in the bathroom were
in the bathroom in a closet or something
you could do it yeah close it is okay
okay okay so perfect so then that's what
you do on the way home you go to the
train station okay great you're gonna be
from here to the train stations find but
this is this is now where you start
building massive confidence This Is It
this is it you walk into the train
station you're terrified I have to make
a video terrifying right I don't have to
make a video I'm terrified right feel
you're already terrified thinking about
it okay so you feel like I'm terrified
awesome
then you have to go find the busiest
part in the train station the busiest
part like not some little bench off the
side okay the busiest part but this is
how you build massive confidence right
the self-respect you walk in it's a huge
organizations like super busy downtown
station you go there I name with
intention you say I'm going to find the
busiest point in your new station look
around where is everybody hanging out
not under the stairwell somewhere the
busiest part and then you go make your
video oh yeah okay that's the challenge
but but then but then even the videos
expected to suck yeah to be brutal be
like post seconds on like beer right
yeah yeah and then you're like oh my god
I did it this
raising up cuz he did it cuz he found
the busiest part and you did it and
anytime you feel that judgment then you
have to go up and do it so even if like
it's okay instead of a story easily yeah
what a second what whatever the most
scariest thing is that's that's the one
to do whether it's Instagram stories or
Twitter or Facebook live or whatever a
service stories it's not as scarce or
Facebook because it's like oh it's gonna
go on 24 then do Facebook oh my gosh
yeah of course like a lot of people like
awesome guys I'm here but it's gonna be
the best one of all time they're gonna
love your thing more than they've ever
loved anything but even they don't like
forget those friends those guys suck
you're you're in the business party news
Asian guys I'm so scared
I'm in the business part of unison but I
don't want to feel afraid to do the
thing to be myself I don't want to be
afraid to be myself in any situation and
I'm afraid so I'm here to eat that
judgement because I want to be confident
and I want to be myself everywhere I go
whether that's then you keep going or
whether you end it there so you did it
you did the thing okay cool well thank
you for coming by thank you for stepping
outside your comfort zone - it's awesome
I appreciate it the most important word
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon this interview was done as
a part of my Toronto workshop if you
want more details on the next one to
sign up check out the link right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there